hey how's it going friends - today we're
going to play a game that I personally
really love you may have heard of it
before it called The Binding of Isaac
rebirth The Binding of Isaac after birth
is coming up very soon he might be out
already while we're playing this um I
haven't played this game too much but a
fair bit and it's just so much fun
this game really innovated
procedurally-generated games which
basically means you can play this game
an infinite amount of times it will be
different every time so you can
basically spend your whole life playing
this game and it will probably still be
fun we're gonna play as madellaine
because I think she's probably the best
character so for those II I'm gonna
explain the game in case you don't know
for those who don't know you walk
through it's very much alike Zelda on
NES when you go through all the rooms
the goal is to go to down as many
flowers as possible and finally you will
reach the final boss which is your mom
great boss great idea and your character
will get different kind of upgrades as
well which is really cool so basically
every time you finish the game you will
look a completely different I look right
now like something hit my head I don't
know what that is but I'll take it
here's the boss room we find her already
we might as well go in let's do it
usually the first bosses are pretty
simple I hope I should probably kill the
tiny one first right I think that he's
the real [ __ ] oh he wakes up when you
shoot him
yay hopefully we'll beat the game while
I'll do this this is my first attempt
[ __ ] your baby god damn it's so annoying
I think the music in this game is it's
it's it's alright but I usually what I
do is I'll find my favorite old-school
soundtrack and I'll put that on instead
and it's really [ __ ] awesome I really
recommend trying that so far so good I
think we're doing pretty good I think it
would be amazing we could actually beat
the game I'm sorry if you're new to this
game and this doesn't make any sense I'm
trying to make this like somewhat
understandable for anyone so yeah here's
the golden room it
years on each time every every floor it
has an upgrade we have you can become
the bomb
that's pretty [ __ ] I'm not gonna grab
that actually I prefer the hard way
better so since everything is randomized
in the game like the upgrades and all
that [ __ ] sometimes you can get amazing
character like your character will just
be so overpowered but sometimes your
characters you can just be straight-up
[ __ ] it looked like we explored all the
floors mas TRO I think this is probably
one of the easiest bosses in the game
it's pretty simple those other two
characters aren't really doing it it
probably me and my staff played this
game a lot too so if you have a
girlfriend or friend that you want to
play a game with this is a great game
usually she will shoot the the tears and
I will control the character what the
[ __ ] is this lag are you [ __ ] kidding
me I need a new computer that's the
[ __ ] disgrace she'd be able to play
this on a [ __ ] potato we gotta kill
these why is it lagging I can't see my
health anymore I wonder what's up with
that there's something I did wrong
so far it's not really going too well I
don't think our upgrades are that strong
but to be fair we only done two floors
can we do it Bryce are you gonna stick
in this whole video I think it'd be cool
okay leaves should be easy I don't never
mind [ __ ] me god damn it
god I hate the shits the [ __ ] post
they're so cute I want to cuddle them
okay so also if you're like a veteran of
this game feel free to give me tips I'm
still looking for ways to get better I
know there's it's just one of those game
where you like you keep learning new
stuff all the time even though you
played it for hours and hours which i
think is really cool it has a lot of
depth to it that's what I'm trying to
say I hate these if you don't do enough
damage you gotta kill them well they're
a little blob there we go that did the
trick didn't it Oh God Oh God we're in
trouble
brain trouble brain trouble [ __ ] me
god damn it we're doing really shitty
aren't we all right [ __ ] this boss he
should have a good upgrade of oh god I
don't remember it oh god it's so dark I
think we could actually die here I'm not
kidding
we have nothing good nothing so you
might in my balls don't even reach him
and I
even know my health like what's my house
bro Oh God ah ah I'm stressed out this
would be so easy by a better [ __ ] why
don't I have better [ __ ] ah [ __ ] you hit
me okay this is bad we're probably on
her last breath I gotta go
gotta get there ah come on almost we can
do is we can it well Wow that was close
come on baby [ __ ] you're not even
playing at Hard difficulty why are you
being such a [ __ ] because I'm awesome
there we go
more health we don't need more health
look how ugly we are already [ __ ]
hell I hate these they scare the [ __ ]
out of me
oh god I hate face I hate so many things
I hate these so much because you can't
shoot them until they pop up they're
[ __ ] giraffe Nick whoa okay tower
what does that do
oh it is bumps it oh god oh god oh god
die die die die die die die die ah ah
this is not a good run it's just not a
kid run but we're holding in there and
I'm proud of myself
I hate these as well hate them with a
passion because they keep running away
and I want them all to die oh god a
big-ass [ __ ] spider okay
we're gonna go in that room if this
sacrifice are hard to go in you could
get [ __ ] all in these rooms but you
could get something good so we're just
gonna try that looks good
that's damage smart yeah we can do more
damage okay worth it worth it we're
doing good okay let's go and do the boss
this is pretty easy boss we do more
damage now I don't know without that's
what it did but this should be make it
even more easy okay we got him poisoned
pretty easy
Freddy's you just kind of zigzag through
this [ __ ] Jimmy fire I haven't watched
other people there to play this game or
anything like that so everything that I
know it's just things I discovered so
don't hate on me if I miss something
like obvious
all right we're going closer to mom goes
to the final boss doing a better still
not good I would say
god I hate
yes die I hate these the sound effect of
them are pretty amazing though god damn
it's [ __ ] creepy this game I never
played it with sound before there we go
what do we get speed and range we needed
speed and range so [ __ ] it we're doing
it and not super good but pretty good oh
god I never be I never I never seen this
boss before that's crazy there's so many
there's so many bosses in the game
alright it shouldn't be too hard I think
we can do it let's see if we can do
without taking any damage Oh God oh [ __ ]
I [ __ ] up we were really gonna
struggle later unless we get more damage
ASAP there we go come on come on come on
just die already a little [ __ ]
there you go mate [ __ ] off what do we
get speed up god damn it [ __ ] it's gonna
be exhausting to redo all this [ __ ]
talking constantly Jesus Christ
alright I just hope we can do it oh god
oh god god damn it [ __ ] sounded vague
like I just spit a break okay never seen
this before what does it do mega tears
okay alright
oh [ __ ] it is a lot of damage isn't it
it's this Christ oh it's kind of like a
shotgun isn't it oh [ __ ] yeah just a lot
of damage it's pretty awesome
I like it it doesn't shoot that fast but
okay there's a chance after all
boström yeah [ __ ] it
oh it's mom [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah ah I'm so about it mom I'm so
about a mom
[ __ ] me let me shoot way too slow god
I'm stressed out so I think Edmond they
get the guy who made the game the story
is based on how he grew up I mean
obviously it's not real but everybody's
on how inspired I guess you could say
how he grew grew up in a very religious
home okay that wasn't too bad tears and
shot speed up okay now it starts to get
actually difficult I would say we got
two more floors for the final if we can
beat this round I don't beat the game
every time I play it let's just say that
like it just does not happen that
frequently oh [ __ ] look at that okay
there is hope cuz we can just one shot
everything so I think on these last two
floors there's no golden room so
honestly as soon as we find the boss
room I think we should just go speed
down no thanks
no thank you very much so far so good
then I think we're doing alright I'm
really happy that we might actually do
this on the first try that's pretty oh
god I didn't know mom was in here
[ __ ] [ __ ] yes there it is
there's the next level we've barely
cleared out anything but [ __ ] life
time oh my god the spiders are [ __ ]
amazing look at that look at that [ __ ]
HP tears up shuts P down uh that's not
ideal
hey uh doing pretty awesome oh god I
hate these these are my worst enemy
sounds disgusting - nothing sounds like
popping a [ __ ] sick look at a
character so cute
I guess cute is not the right word
actually I'm I remember the first time I
play this game the first way I play the
original version of my psyche or
whatever came out ik probably the same -
oh god oh god I got good at the same
time as I started doing youtube I think
I did one video of it but I would slow
down my computer purposely so the game
would run slower so that it would be
easier for me to dodge all the
projectiles shameful and admitting
honestly if we find the last boss I
think we're good to go like we're pretty
but we're not like Opie but we're buffed
and Arcade awesome music scam bo say
move again don't need that okay
we got a dollar said ah lives we found
the bathroom life signing your lemons we
got more what oh this is gonna be so
easy this give me oh this is not the
last boss oh [ __ ] I made a mistake
no is it it looks different it looks
different isn't it
let's see says son didn't do [ __ ] what I
use the Sun I don't know the [ __ ] is
that what is that we beat it it's it's
it's supposed to end there I don't know
what's going on Oh God we're going
deeper
oh god this never happened before no I'm
not that Opie [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what's that
[ __ ] these explode I'm sweating balls
oh I'm looking for like an awesome
upgrade I don't know what boss happens
after this one yeah what are you gonna
do mate oh god I'm killing angels and
[ __ ] now scheme got a really weird
really just theme and I don't know what
that [ __ ] is this are we doing how are
we holding up think pretty good oh god
it's gonna explode
[ __ ] this spider is my best friend I
love you speedy speedy that's that's a
name yeah very creative I don't want to
[ __ ] up now I'd be so pissed huh all
right here goes nothing Bryce vs. Isaac
[ __ ] oh my god ah stop shooting me Isaac
no we keep getting hit this nut kid
that's not good than good ah come on oh
I don't know what's going on oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah we got my house
awesome awesome awesome ah keep sure to
keep shooting go Spidey speedy go speedy
ah
come on get over here how did I get here
ha [ __ ] that I get it oh he's double sin
come on
yeah we got an achievement so glad what
I got this [ __ ] round on tape awesome
yeah yeah whoo whoo I there is a story
there I don't get it
feel free to tell me about the Lauren
[ __ ] we unlock the relic so there you go
that was the Binding of Isaac rebirth we
got another piece of the puzzle
need two more cool cool cool cool
thank you bros for watching this is so
much fun I had a blast
how long did we how long do we do this
45 minutes well thank you so much for
just hanging out for 45 minutes that's
amazing
go get this game if you haven't already
and I'll see you bros in the next video
stay awesome
what is this trophy what is this trophy
you